when i retire maybe i'll look at this
because there's something very strange
about
sleep and time that is utterly
paradoxical
and what i mean by this is you can say
okay i've got to wake up
cause i'm going to um you know i'm gonna
fly out and meet matt walker in berkeley
in in
you know we're gonna grab coffee and
i've got to get this early morning
flight from lax
and you set your alarm for you know five
o'clock in the morning
and guaranteed you will wake up at 4 50.
100 percent how is that right possible
it happens too frequently for it to be
you know just by chance so somewhere
your brain has this quartz like
precision
of clock counting however
there is an absence of time particularly
in
dreaming because all of us have probably
had that experience that our alarm goes
off
and we were in this strange dream and
then we hit the snooze button and our
snooze button is just two minutes
and we go back and we go right back into
the dream again
and then the snooze button goes off and
you think
now hang on a second i was that felt
like almost an
hour of an experience so
there is this temporal mismatch
where when we go into the dream state we
can almost fold and compress
time like a concertina it's like
inception yeah and i think it's no big
surprise that nolan picked up on that
you know with the help of maybe some
you know sleep um specialists uh
offering that advice we know that
you get this you know this dilation i've
called it's a
dream dilation or dream time dilation
where time went along the time right
like so what do you what do you make of
that like what would be
the evolutionary advantage of that well
it may be that there is no necessarily
evolutionary advantage but there may be
a brain mechanism that explains
it because what we know is that memories
are replayed during both deep sleep and
rem sleep
now when we are in deep sleep memories
are actually sped up
the brain will actually be replaying
those memories anywhere between five to
20 times
faster but when we go into dream sleep
the replay is actually much slower
and so that may be why you know if you
if you want to speak about um
that's that's usually the one question i
i i look forward to lisa
when i give talks someone put the hand
up and say is inception possible
and my heart just sinks i start seeing a
spinning top and the music that comes by
but you know i think that that's why
nolan had that beautiful idea that when
you descend
down into these different levels of
sleep
you know a minute of time in the real
world
could be you know five minutes of time
in the dream world and then if he gets
you to deeper dream states you know
then you know a minute of time in the
real world is
two hours or two days or 50 years well
with the premise being
i'm gonna anchor this memory or this
concept or this idea
in this human's brain and the way to do
that
how do you do that in an effective way
where it's going to stay
right and when you when you think about
this in the context of
of you know morphing time constructs if
you have
a dream state in which memories are
accelerated that's certainly going to
aid in
the development of skill acquisition
right like you're repeating a memory or
a behavior
or just imagine you know you're in jiu
jitsu and you learned a new maneuver or
whatever and you're replaying that in
your mind of course
that's going to anchor that and then the
slowing down is almost like a
visualization
well but both of those things would work
in tandem
to really you know sort of calcify
neural pathways around
like a new concept oh you need to feel
it you need to be a scientist rich
would you direct my sleep sensitivity my
mom would be very happy
about the medical no you're too precious
in what you do otherwise
um but so you're absolutely right that i
think
what we know is that deep sleep will um
one of its functions
is that it will hit the save button on
your memories
so that you don't forget so deep sleep
will future proof that information
within the brain
and in part it's just as you said it's
deep sleep that's basically
scoring the memory trace almost etching
it you know
into um the the glass of the brain
but then you know dream sleep comes
along
and what we've realized is that dream
sleep does something very different from
memories
sleep is much more intelligent than we
ever gave it credit when it comes to
information processing
sleep not only strengthens individual
memories
it will intelligently stitch and
associate those new memories together
and it seems to be during sleep
particularly during dream sleep
when we perform it's almost like
informational alchemy
um or it's like group therapy for
memories maybe that's a better analogy
you know that um sleep gathers in all of
this information that you've been
learning during the day and everyone
gets a name badge
but sleep forces you to go and speak to
the people not at the front of the room
that you think i've got the most obvious
connection with
it forces you to speak to the people at
the back of the room that you think
you've got no connection with at all
now it turns out that you do and it's a
non-obvious connection
but it's a potentially powerful one
nonetheless
because when you start to fuse things
together that shouldn't normally go
together
but offer marked advances in
evolutionary fitness
it sounds like the biological basis of
creativity
and that's where we see dream sleep
providing a benefit
you wake up the next day with a revised
mind
wide web of associations and you are
capable
of defining solutions to previously
impenetrable
problems it's the reason that you've
never been told
to stay awake on a problem right sleep
on a problem but it's a it has a very
strange and elusive relationship with
memory like memory doesn't seem to
really
be required for this right like
sometimes you will the recollection
you remember some of this stuff and then
it fades but nonetheless
the brain is doing its job in that state
and you're able to
come up with a creative solution or
solve a problem that mystified you the
night before
yeah and i have another it's probably
second only to the idiocy of my idea
that we
never evolved sleep that we we we have
you know it was from sleep that
wakefulness emerged that we started at
the top of the uh the podcast
the other stupid theory is that in fact
we remember all of our dreams
you know most of us when we wake up we
if we can remember a dream it's it's
usually very difficult
and different people have different
dream recall strengths
and the harder that we try you know the
right
unlike the more unlikely it is but
i think that that's not a problem of
memory imprinting
i think that's a difference in memory
science that we call
accessibility versus availability
i think one when we wake up in the
morning
we lose the ip address to the memory so
we can't find it
so it's availability is prevented
but i believe it's accessibility it's
it's still present there
we just can't so sort of so sorry it's
i've got that wrong
it's availability is still there but its
accessibility
is prevented and the reason i i think
this is a tenable theory and i've got
some
ideas as how to test it is because you
can wake up in the morning think oh i
was having this incredible dream
and and and you just can't bring it back
to mind and you think okay
it's just gone and then two or three
days later
you're walking down the street and you
see a sign or you're in the shower and
you see the shampoo bottle
and all of a sudden there's a cue that
triggers the unleashing of that dream
memory and it all comes flooding back
in other words that memory was there all
along
you just didn't have accessibility to a
still yet available and present memory
now if that's true what it could mean is
that
we store all of our dreams
and the reason i find that sort of hand
waving wacky and fun philosophically to
think about is
we know that memory operates largely in
a non-conscious manner
you know you can for example if you're
walking up a set of stairs and you've
you know
you've got your pad of paper and you've
left a drink on the stairs
you know you sort of you're reaching
down to pick it up that's an immensely
complex challenge you had to
sort of compute the physics of where
your hand was you had to know what the
weight of that cup was it's all based on
memory
and it operates way below the radar of
consciousness
most memories do if that's true
that our behavior is certainly
influenced non-consciously by
our memories it's what we call implicit
memory
and we remember many of our dreams then
all of a sudden it becomes interesting
to ask
how much does our waking life
reflect or is shaped by our stored
dreams
in an unconscious way in an unconscious
way now this is getting very freudian
and i i have to say i'm not a big
advocate of freud i think he
um you know he did a remarkable service
to
the science of sleep he brought dreams
into the world of the mind
before it was you know in the greeks it
was coming from gods you know
hypnos somnas you know um morpheus
and then chinese cultures had an idea
that it dreams came from the soul
but it was freud who actually placed
dreaming squirrelly
within the mind in other words freud
made dream science
a domain of brain science of
neuroscience now after that it all kind
of went south you know and i often joke
that
i think freud was 50 percent right and
100 percent wrong
yeah and so and it's not when it got
into their
exactly and that's just and we've
demonstrated that it's why it's no
longer embraced by the scientific
community as a scientific hypothesis
because it's untestable it has no solid
predictions
um and i think it's good to keep in mind
that you know there are some reports
that at the time freud was doing enough
cocaine to kill a small horse when he
was coming up with some of that too so
maybe you wanted
to cocaine yeah i know what is it about
me i can't seem to get away from it so
um so i think i i have this
enamored theory about um dreaming and
it's just
not very fundable so it's hard to get
the uh the funds
i mean i think it's the ultimate you
know
unknown terrain and i'll and just
unbelievably fascinating like the idea
that our brain is so complex and it's
it's it's performing this
mystical dance and computation while we
sleep
and the extent to which we barely begin
to understand what that's all about
i think it's just super interesting
[Music]
you